so if you've been in the Dragon Ball
Community long enough Azar you've heard
of the Big Green dub
[Music]
let that child alone but what if I told
you there was another official dub that
is arguably worse enter Speedy dump this
Malaysian dub produced by Speedy video
Distributors only ever covered the
dragon ball movies but oh man
now I see black human beings dislike the
sound of rubbing glass probably the
sound wave of the whistle which a human
being rules might equal something
irritating the ears of dynamic people I
mean I just what do you even say to that
like I could go through and talk about
them calling namekians Namek people or
Goten Paco or King Kai gay King gay King
what you have done was wonderful gay
King what have I done I'm very old but
ultimately there is just no describing
this thing